oui 21 millions en 122 1211
proportion de oui
81,7 non 4 millions sept cent soixante
sept mille 180
en portions
18,3 pour ça le 28 septembre plus de 4
français sur 5 adhèrent à ces
institutions un pays d'afrique la guinée
a voté non et c'est donc exclus de la
communauté française la constitution est
promulguée par le président rené coty le
4 octobre 1958 désormais il s'agit de
mettre en place les institutions pour le
général de gaulle le premier test c'est
d'organiser les législatives
elles auront lieu le 23 et le 30
novembre de la même année à cette
occasion il abandonne le scrutin
proportionnel de la quatrième république
la quatrième république qui était un
régime des partis avaient voulu
instaurer un scrutin proportionnel de
manière à ne laisser aucun des
partenaires des coalitions
gouvernementales qui était au pouvoir
pour le général de gaulle l'état
d'esprit est différent
ce qui lui importe c'est de construire
une majorité stable est importante pour
que le pouvoir exécutif puisse justement
initié sa politique et donc le scrutin
qui est choisi c'est un scrutin
majoritaire un scrutin majoritaire de
circonscription appelle ça uninominal
parce qu'il correspond justement à la
volonté pour le général de gaulle de
construire une véritable majorité
présidentielle la campagne de 58 elle se
fait sur d'abord des nouveaux candidats
bien grand coup de balai de ceux qui
étaient déjà là sous la ivème
qui s'occupe survécu quand même mais
phénomène de nouveauté des nouveaux
candidats qui surgissent allez on change
on chante on oublie le passé
les fronts s'ils suivent l'homme du
référendum toutes les grandes figures de
la quatrième république sont battus
d'edouard daladier à pierre mendès
france en passant par françois
mitterrand ou bien encore le communiste
jacques duclos le général de gaulle a
gagné son pari la nouvelle république
est sur les rails avec une majorité
gouvernementale et nouveautés ces
élections législatives vont permettre la
mise en place d'un parlementarisme
rationnalisé une expression qui date de
l'après première guerre mondiale dont
qui consiste à dire le parlement est là
le parlement a deux fonctions
fondamentales voter la loi contre le
gouvernement ça il ya un accord total là
dessus depuis toujours mais en même
temps il faut que les règles relatives
au fonctionnement du parlement les
règles relatives aux relations entre le
parlement et le gouvernement soit
organisée de telle manière qu'il y ait
la plus grande stabilité possible pour
le gouvernement et qu'en tout cas le
parlement soit dans une situation où il
ne bloque pas le travail du gouvernement
taxé d un parlement où on discute - on
délibère - on passe moins de temps à des
controverses houleuses l'exécutif et il
devient gouvernante autonome a plus de
poids
l'exécutif prend désormais ses marques
les nouvelles institutions ne remettent
pas en cause le mode d'élection du
président de la république ni la durée
du mandat présidentiel
par rapport aux institutions de la
troisième de la quatrième république
dans lesquelles seuls les parlementaires
y lisait le chef de l'état le collège
électoral présidentiel et hilario
conseillers généraux aux membres des
assemblées les territoires d'outre-mer
et aux représentants d'élus des conseils
municipaux
le général de gaulle est élu par un
collège d'environ 80 mille personnes qui
sont pour l'essentiel des délégués des
conseils municipaux face aux candidats
en lice l'élection se résume à une
formalité le 21 décembre 1958 charles de
gaulle est élu président avec 78,5 % des
suffrages face au communiste georges
marrane et aux mathématiciens albert
châtelet qui ont fait de la figuration
ça lui donne une assise un peu plus
importantes comme l'était celle des
présidents de la troisième ou la
quatrième république le 8 janvier 1959
charles de gaulle est investi président
de la république il est alors saluons
ces termes par rené coty
[Musique]
mirambeau mais nouveau président de la
république nomme michel debré premier
ministre et le général va peser sa
signature très rapidement il va avec
rené coty à l'arc de triomphe pour
ranimer la flamme du soldat inconnu
ensuite il repart l'elysée seules en
abandonnant rené coty son
s'occuper de lui le moins du monde au
fond ils n'acceptent pas d'être le
successeur de rené coty qui ne tient pas
personnellement l'an grande estime il
est le premier président d'une vème
république qui vient de naître et donc
comme il le dira dans
ses mémoires d'espoir me voici désormais
à l'elysée les institutions sont
acceptés de l'elysée comment vais-je les
modeler l'homme du 18-juin aime les
symboles et il s'agit de marquer de son
empreinte la constitution dès les
premières lignes les pouvoirs du
président de la république sont définis
dont le titre 2 de la constitution alors
qu'il n'apparaissait qu'en cinquième
position dans la précédente le présent
la république à la première place des
institutions ce qui montre aussi
immédiatement la volonté du constituant
un lecteur de la constitution d'accorder
une place particulière au chef de l'état
la priorité présent appliquée
gouvernement c'est à prix était de
l'exécutif donc de la stabilité donc de
l'efficacité de l'action gouvernementale
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs michel debré
utilisera l'image
architectural du président de la
république clé de voûte qui a choisi la
force parlementaire et la force
gouvernementale et ce qui tient ses
présidents dont l'esprit du général et
dans sa pratique c'est le chef de l'état
qui est le véritable chef du
gouvernement la primauté du président de
la république ressort à plusieurs
reprises dans la constitution notamment
dans l'article 5 qui vont retenir le
article 5 6 et le gardien ou le garant
politique que la constitution des
institutions du bon fonctionnement des
institutions de l'intégrité du
territoire des traités c'est à dire que
c'est véritablement une disposition qui
donne et légitime quelque part lusage
par le président de la république de
compétences extraordinaires mais des
compétences réelles par exemple le droit
dissolution par exemple l'appel au
peuple avec le référendum
par exemple la nomination du premier
ministre la constitution de 1958 a donc
posé les premières briques de la vème
république
mais le général de gaulle voit plus loin
il a déjà un coude avance il élabore
dans le secret des ministères il a dit
les hommes politiques en face de moi
jouent à la belote mais moi je joue au
poker
sa première carte ils la jouent en 1960
face à des députés hostiles à son projet
de dissuasion nucléaire ils demandent au
premier ministre michel debré d'utiliser
pour la première fois la procédure de
l'article 49-3 alors l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la constitution mais les
parlementaires dans l'obligation soit
d'accepter le texte du gouvernement soit
de censurer le texte du gouvernement
plus exactement de quoi il s'agit face à
l'absence d'une majorité sur un texte
controversé mais considéré comme étant
décisif essentiel par le pouvoir
exécutif le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité sur le texte qui oblige
l'opposition de déposer une motion de
censure s'il n'ya pas dépôts de motions
de censure
le texte est considéré comme adopté un
an plus tard dans la nuit du 21 avril
1961 et généraux français et leurs
châles jour et salan prennent le
contrôle d'alger pour mettre un terme à
la crise de gaulle s'adresse aux
français le 23 avril à la télévision il
s'attribue en direct les pleins pouvoirs
comme prévu par l'article 16 de la
constitution l'article 16 c'est le
prolongement de l'article 5 c'est à dire
que lorsque l'article 5 est en cause
lorsque l'intégrité du territoire et en
cause lorsque le pl a conduit les
pouvoirs publics est en cause et sont
menacés et c'est bon on peut utiliser
ces pouvoirs exceptionnels on retrouve
là aussi du style de gaulle c'est un
article qui donne quand même les pleins
pouvoirs un homme dans des situations de
crise et quand je dis les pleins
pouvoirs c'est vraiment les pleins
pouvoirs pour un exécutif pouvoirs
législatif judiciaire tout l'art mais
les pouvoirs civils et préfet la police
etc c'est ce qu'on appelle un pouvoir
d'exception l'article 16
son origine ce sont les souvenirs de
1940 il faut toujours se souvenir que
ceux qui écrivent la constitution de 58
avait 20 ans de moins en 1938 c'est à
dire au moment de la crise de munich et
du déclenchement de la guerre et c'est
très très présent dans l'eure dans leur
esprit et dans leur réaction c'est
l'idée que lorsque la france est en
péril il faut que le président de la
république puisse l'incarner
complètement l'article 16 est une
réponse à l'histoire parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce qui peut se passer dans notre
pays on ne sait pas d'ailleurs qu'un
pays c'est pas une eau dormante
après la signature des accords d'evian
du 18 mars 1962 qui met fin à huit ans
de guerre entre l'algérie et la france
le général de gaulle va montrer une
nouvelle fois qu'il est le maître du jeu
en désaccord avec michel debré sur la
question algérienne il décide alors de
l'écarter le président de la république
demande au premier ministre michel debré
de démissionner alors que l'assemblée
nationale
vient de lui voter la confiance à une
forte majorité donc ils montrent que ils
négligent le vote de l'assemblée
nationale s'il appartient bien au
président de la république et à lui seul
de nommer le premier ministre il n'a pas
le pouvoir de le destituer seule
l'assemblée nationale peut renverser le
gouvernement par des procédures bien
défini soit en lui refusant la confiance
lorsqu'il engage sa responsabilité soit
en votant une motion de censure
entraînant sa chute c'est à dire que
pour faire tomber un gouvernement il ne
faut pas assembler les gens qu'ils
rencontrent
il faut que les gens qui sont content
puisse avoir la solution de remplacement
ce sont les mécanismes qui régissent les
articles et 49 et 50 de la constitution
mais le général de gaulle va passer
outre pain pour général de gaulle qui
expliquait en 58 devant le comité
consultatif constitutionnel que jamais
un présent n'applique pouvait virer un
premier ministre parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'on est dans un autre type de
régime là il le fait tranquillement et
nomma premier sans même demander l'avis
du dudu du parlement on a compris en 62
c'était ça
il va nommer pour remplacer michel debré
georges pompidou que personne sauf le
petit cénacle des initiés ne connais qui
n'est pas parlementaire qui n'est pas un
homme politique
qui comme principal le garantis pour le
général de gaulle d'avoir été son
directeur de cabinet ça présente une
autre vertu pour le présent de la
république et un chef de gouvernement
c'est que il n'y a pas de pression
particulière de chantage particulier du
ministre vis-à-vis du chef de
gouvernement et vis-à-vis du présent la
république le général de gaulle voulait
que les mini soit indépendant des
parlementaires ne soit pas sous
influence des parlementaires est soi
même détachée du parlement c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs général de gaulle a
recruté de très nombreux ministres
pendant l'exercice de ce pouvoir en
dehors du parlement renforcé le pouvoir
de l'exécutif le solidifier c'est toute
l'ambition du général de gaulle à ce
moment là que le général de gaulle te
dis il faut qu'on passe à l'élection au
suffrage universel direct c'est la seule
façon d'assurer la pérennité de la
primauté présidentielle mais un autre
événement va renforcer sa conviction le
22 août 1962 le général échappe
miraculeusement à un attentat au
petit-clamart organisées par les
partisans de l'algérie française
une question désormais se pose et si de
gaulle venait à disparaître
que se passerait-il c'est l'attentât du
petit clamart qui fait dire au général
de gaulle attention j'aurai un
successeur il faut préparer la
légitimité de ce successeur pour moi pas
de problème j'avais cette légitimité ce
prestige de héros du 18 juin 1940
mais ceux qui vont me suivre auront
besoin d'une légitimité du suffrage
universel pour s'imposer aux assemblées
il est persuadé qu'il faut aller vite
car il est mortel
d'autant plus que certains veulent
savoir politiques et d'autres sa mort
physique
et c'est comme ça que on va rentrer dans
le référendum de 1962 sur l'élection du
président à buc au suffrage universel
pour réviser la constitution dans le
texte de 1958 il y à une disposition
particulière
c'est l'article 89 la marge de manoeuvre
est étroite alors comment imposer cette
révision à une classe politique qui n'en
veut pas cette disposition particulière
permet au président de la république
d'engager un processus de révision à
deux conditions la première c'est qu'il
ya un accord en termes identiques entre
les députés et les sénateurs et la
deuxième il faut que ce texte soit
ratifié soit par trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires réunis à versailles en
congrès soit par référendum
du coup il est certain que le texte ne
sera pas voté dans des termes identiques
par les deux chambres part du conseil
des ministres du 12 septembre 1962 il
propose de recourir à l'article 11 en
vertu duquel le président de la
république peut soumettre au référendum
tout projet de loi portant sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics le
20 septembre il présente son projet aux
français
mais comme toujours
je ne peux et ne veux rien accomplir
qu'avec votre cocon comme toujours
je vais donc bientôt vous le demandez
alors comme toujours c'est vous qui en
déciderez la quasi-totalité des juristes
et tout style et la méthode employée par
le général de gaulle les juristes qui
réagissent plutôt sur les modalités de
la révision de la constitution puisque
le jeu vers de gaulle va utiliser
l'article 11 de la constitution qui est
un article prévu pour faire un effort
législatif
et il va pas utiliser l'article 89 de la
constitution qui est l'article prévu
pour réviser la constitution donc ils
disent les juristes disent en substance
cela il ya violation des règles
constitutionnelles
le conseil d'état émet alors un avis
défavorable l'utilisation de l'article
11 le conseil constitutionnel se déclare
incompétent quant à la classe politique
elle est vent debout contre le projet de
révision cette annonce va faire
l'unanimité pratiquement contre le
général de gaulle à la seule exception
de son propre parti du parti gaulliste
de l'umr le parti communiste
se déclare évidemment contre
cette idée les autres partis politiques
des socialistes aux indépendants en
passant par les radicaux les mrp cetera
vont constituer un cartel des noms pour
demander aux français de voter non à
cette réforme constitutionnelle
à la tête du cartel des noms on trouve
notamment le président du sénat gaston
monnerville au congrès du parti radical
le 29 septembre ce dernier qualifie de
forfaiture la méthode employée par de
gaulle mais celui ci est inflexible et
c'est ce qui conduit l'assemblée
nationale a voté le 5 octobre une motion
de censure contre le gouvernement
pompidou le cartel des no 7 collier deux
hommes politiques la plupart de la 4e et
ces gens là sont pas rendu compte que
dans l'esprit du public c'était le passé
contre l'avenir parce qu'ils avaient été
très cité connue qui disait mis en avant
sous la quatrième république ils avaient
tous été 10 x 15 x 20 x ministre sur la
quatrième il arrive elle a usé pour eux
le régime politique de la france ne peut
être qu'un régime dans lequel la clé de
voûte des institutions c'est pas le
présent la plus que c'est le parlement à
la tribune l'assemblée nationale
gc 10 physiquement
que le mauvais génie d'autrefois étaient
de nouveau présents dans l'hémicycle
j'ai vu la grande majorité de
l'assemblée nationale depuis les
communistes inclus jusqu'au
sympathisants de l'eau as également
d'inclure je les ai vues animées
- par le désir d'exercer un droit de
contrôle légitime de la politique du
gouvernement
que par la passion de renverser tout ce
qui s'oppose au règne exclusif des
partis qui est-ce qui visait c'est pas
c'est pas compliqué celui qui est visé
c'est présent de la république et c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui amène la crise c'est à
dire que c'est le seul gouvernement
renversé de la vème république mais
c'est aussi immédiatement derrière une
dissolution c'est que les parlementaires
croit encore qu'il est possible
d'atteindre le président à pluie qu'à
travers son premier ministre le général
réplique aussitôt alors que le
gouvernement pompidou a été mise en
minorité il le reconduit dans ses
fonctions et prononce la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
de nouvelles élections législatives sont
prévues pour les 18 et 25 novembre
1962 mais avant cela du gold 1 consulter
les français par référendum la campagne
du référendum nous sommes deux elle se
fait sur le suffrage universel n'oubliez
pas la majorité c'est vous thème qui
sera repris en soit cette la majorité
c'est vous c'est à dire chaque français
se sent concerné en la décision du chef
de l'état met à d'esprit des français
c'est
une immense reconnaissance au général de
gaulle d'avoir arrêté la guerre
d'algérie et puis également une
reconnaissance du fait que depuis son
arrivée au pouvoir la france à 1
vision internationale qu'elle n'avait
pas auparavant que le général de gaulle
est une voix qu'on écoute que l'économie
française se porte bien que le contrôle
de l'état sur l'économie
il permet une augmentation permanente
des revenus donc il y a à la fois des
opposants incontestablement au nom des
principes politiques et en même temps
une satisfaction des français sur les
résultats de l'action du président de la
république et c'est sur cette balance là
que va se dérouler le référendum
d'octobre
1962 le oui l emporte alors avec un peu
plus de 60% des suffrages
on n'a pas une majorité aussi éclatante
qu'en 1958 pour les institutions de la
vème république
mais c'est quand même une majorité
confortable
60% des suffrages exprimés en faveur
donc de cette révision
constitutionnelle est donc ça donne un
surcroît de légitimité un surcroît de
prestige au général de gaulle
les partis traditionnels sont battus ils
le seront de nouveau aux élections
législatives des 18 et 25 novembre
lui est né un gaulliste et leurs alliés
les républicains indépendants obtienne
la majorité absolue des sièges
l'assemblée nationale
c'est une nouvelle victoire du général
de gaulle c'est quand même la première
fois qu'on a une vraie majorité à
l'assemblée nationale les élections du
18 et du 25 novembre donne une majorité
qui va stable cohérente et homogène
c'est un grand grand événement dans la
vie politique française c'est là qu'on
rend dingue nouveau monde avant ces des
tâtonnements avancé dé des histoires de
conjoncture avant on est encore pendant
la guerre d'algérie dont beaucoup de
choses s'expliquent par la peur des
conséquences de la guerre d'algérie à
partir de 62 on est vraiment sous la
vème république c'est ce que raymond
aron a appelé je crois à juste titre la
deuxième naissance de la vème république
s'ils voulaient la constitution est né
en 1958 la vème république en tant que
régime politique avec le poids de son
président et son système majoritaire
même y compris ces périodes de
cohabitation est né à l'automne 1962 à
la fin de l'année 62 de gaulle à a
réalisé le grand chelem il a à ses
institutions de la vème république il à
la présidence de la république qui
désormais sera
concrétiser enraciné couronné par le
suffrage universel
et puis il a une majorité parlementaire
totalement à ses ordres il va pouvoir
véritablement mettre en oeuvre toutes
ces réformes et je dirais exercer la
constitution de la vème république
dans toute sa plénitude la constitution
de 1958 porte indéniablement l'empreinte
du général de gaulle si elle n'a pas
encore battu le record en durée de la
troisième république
elle a permis à la france d'être
gouvernée démocratiquement bien au delà
de la disparition du général il reste
une constitution qui s'adapte aux
contextes nationaux internationaux
économiques politiques sociaux qui
résiste à tous les alternances les
cohabitations il faut bien constater que
la constitution d'un cinquième
république est un une sorte de véhicule
tout terrain parce qu'elle s'adapte à
toutes les situations politiques depuis
60 ans la grande force de cette
constitution de la vème république
c'est d'avoir été suffisamment ambigu
dans sa formulation pour lui permettre
de s'adapter à plusieurs époques la vème
république
c'est à la fois le temps pour gouverner
légitimité qui permet la continuité de
l'action en même temps le contrôle
populaire
m